congressman Elon omar nor alleys now
using a new tactic against Donald Trump
of the GOP so after the president ding
the freshmen rap in a tweet over her
insensitive comments about 9/11 the
freshman rep said that the mere
criticism of her was akin to the
incitement of violence the media echo
chamber of course was quick to highlight
her concerns the freshman congresswoman
says she has seen an increase in direct
threats against her life after President
Trump tweeted a video mixing footage of
the congresswoman who is Muslim giving a
recent speech with footage of the 9/11
attacks Nancy Pelosi is asking the US
Capitol Police to conduct a security
assessment for congresswoman Omar the
speaker is one of many Democrats now
accusing the president of trying to
incite violence against the first term
lawmaker joining me now is Ben Shapiro
The Daily wires editor-in-chief and
author of the brand-new book the right
side of history which is fantastic Ben
now this isn't about free speech is
about downplaying one of the darkest
days in our nation's history your take
that's of course true and she has a long
history of not taking terrorism
particularly seriously in 2013 in an
interview in Minnesota in which she
joked about people taking al Qaeda and
Hezbollah more serious than they took
America and England and then in 2016 she
wrote a letter in which she tried to
have a judge be more lenient with people
who tried to join Isis saying that of
course these were people who only became
violent because of American
marginalization and then in 2017 she
wrote a column for Time magazine in
which she suggested that America was
rooted and founded on slavery and
genocide and in order for us not to look
that in the face instead we focused on
international terror this is not someone
who takes terrorism particularly
seriously so I am bewildered as to why
quoting her would constitute some form
of violation of her person edge would be
violation of free speech or something
nonsensical like that
Ben just so people know what we're
talking about here I want to play that
sound bite that you're referencing
where she talks about the way people say
al Qaeda let's watch I think we when I
was in college I took a terrorism class
every time the
the professor said okay that he sort of
like his shoulders went up and you know
okay and you don't say America with an
intensity you don't say England with the
intensity you know you don't you don't
say the army with an intensity well and
Ben P put a judge we talked about him
earlier he's the he's the new star of
the Democrat Party he's edged out beta
O'Rourke and now he's taken that spot in
the spotlight
he talked today about the consequences
of other rising people like her I
thought you'd love this let's watch one
of the worst things that's happening
right now is authorizing people and if
we're wondering whether this has
real-world consequences look no further
than what happened not long ago in New
Zealand and yes by the way the president
demonizing representative Omar is part
of this it's dangerous and it's going to
stop authorizing Ben well very odd since
representative Omar has three times in
the last three months been chided for
openly anti-semitic statements and then
the democratic party has defended her
I'm amused to watch the Democratic Party
suggest that criticism and quoting of
Ilhan Omar amounts to violent incitement
where representative on our can say
whatever jew-hating thing she wants on a
daily basis and that is not incite but
now I agree it's not incitement in
either case but to pretend that it is
incitement when it stuff you don't like
and it is and it's not incitement one of
stuff that you do seems pretty
irresponsible at the mildest man thank
you thank you thank you so much great to
have you on tonight